بينما يحاول النظام استغلال مذيعه عن حل
شرطه الاخلاق والذي اعتبره البعض شبه
تنازل لاحتواء المتظاهرين تتضح معالم
التكتيكات التي يحاول من خلالها النظام
اسكات الحناجر فالمصدق هو من اتباع النظام
والمشكك هو من صفوف الانتفاضه للاكل
المحتاجون لم يصدقوا تلك المزاعم رغم ان
المدعي العام لرني محمد جعفر منتظري اعلن
ان شرطه الاداب اغلقت صحيفه وسط جونلل عنه
ان النظام الايراني وتحت الضغط بدا مجبرا
على النظر في امكانيه تخفيف بعض قيود
الحجاب
تنقل الصحيفه عن متظاهره عشرينيه قولها ان
اغلاق شرطه الاخلاق محض تضليل يسعى من
خلاله النظام لصرف الانتباه عما يجري
فعليا من دعوات للاحتجاج وايضا يحاول
اثاره الانقسامات في صفوف المحتشين لكن
بكل الاحوال تؤكد المتظاهره ان الغاضبين
لن يقبل الا باسقاط هذا النظام
فالسيل بلغ الزبى والكره وصل مدح نشط
ايرانيه اخرى تدعى التينه دائما استنكرات
خبر حال شرطه الاخلاق وعدته محاوله لنسع
فتيل الانتفاضه من دون تقديم تنازلات
كبيره علي الفنا الخبير في الشؤون
الايرانيه يعتبر ان النظام جعل دوريه
الارشاد كبشه فداء يسد به الافواه المنفذه
منذ مقتل ماسه امينه ماتت امي واشعلت معها
فتيله احتجاجات تمددت من المراه والحياه
والحريه الى اسقط نظام خ
وسنقاتل حتى الموت اذا اضرابات واعتصامات
ادخلت معها القاسي والداني في رب تظاهرات
[موسيقى]
انبسطي مبادئ الدين الى حراسه النظام
ضائعونهم المدنيون ضاقت بهم الحياه ذرعا
بعد عقود من القمع السياسي والاجتماعي
فوجدوا من مقتل امين شعله لتفجير ما اختلج
في قلوبهم يوصلون الاضرابه لليوم الثاني
على التوالي في موجه تستمر ثلاثه ايام
بدات فيها الاسواق خاليه كما نشاهد هجرها
الباعه والمتسوقون علهم يفصلون صوتهم عن
طريق ضرب الشريان الاقتصادي لتلك البسارات
كما اضرب نحو 500 من عمال العقود العاملين
في شركه خزانات بتروك كيماويات في جنوب
غربي ايران
[موسيقى]
صحيفه دي جاردن البريطانيه حاولت ان تحلل
هذه الحركه الاحتجاجيه
وتتخيل الطريقه التي يمكن للشعب بها ان
يقود مضجع النظام بالتفاصيل سردت الصحيفه
بدايه هذه الانتفاضه ومع بدنها بالنساء
وكيف شملت لاحقا المواطنين من مختلف
الطبقات
وكيف تفنن النظام مع كل مظاهره على مدار
العقد ونصف العقد الماضيين ان يقمعها
بمزيج من القسوه والاستغلال ليبدو في كل
مره مدافعا عن نفسه وطبعا تكون هناك
نظريات مؤامره عديده هي الخطه الاسلم
بنظره دائما هذه الخطه الاسلم هذه
التظاهرات التي شبت في السادس عشر من
سبتمبر تبدو بحسب الصحيفه شبيهه بالتظاهره
التي اسقطت حكم الشاه في يناير عام
1979 خاصه وان المظ رات تتجدد في كل مكان
من الشارع الى الجامع وحتى في المقابر فلو
افترضنا ان الغضب خف تقليلا سيشتعل مره
اخرى مع اربعينيه باربعينيه كل متظاهر قتل
على ايدي قوات الامن ما يعني ان دائره
الموت والوحشيه تتسع وفيات فجنازات
فاحتجاجات فقط لا اكثر من ذي قبل وتعادل
الكره الى ان تبلغ ذروتها
وتستنف قوى النظام وتهد كيانه
انتفاضه رواده عشرينيون يجرون ابائهم معهم
ولو بحذر فهذه المره تبدد الخوف ومعاد
لديهم ما يخسرونونه على حد تعبير الجيل
الجدير بالذكر ان هذه الاحتجاجات تختلف عن
سباقاتها كونها وحدت جبهه المعارضه
الايرانيه التي كانت سابقا شبه منقمه فكان
اكثر سهوله الامر الثاني ان الايرانيين في
الخارج كانوا لسانا يدعم المحتجين وبحسب
البيانات فان من بين 92 مليون منشور على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي 60% من هذه
المناشير هي من خارج ايران
[موسيقى]